e
e e
good morning I am going to open up the
subcommittee hearing for house bills 428
244 and 96 representative Davis would
you like to lead us in the pledge
the first bill we're going to be
discussing today is HB
428 um I would like to call Bill Sherman
uh to the table uh to um walk us through
an amendment that has been worked on
with the prime sponsor
good morning mam chair members of the
Committees uh my name is Philip Sherman
I'm the chair of the building code
review board well we don't take a
position on this bill uh on the overall
intent of it um I'm I'm here to provide
some technical input in this proposed
amendment which a number of us have
worked on which would essentially
continue to prohibit technical
amendments but allow administrative
amend M ments and we can get into what
that what that really means uh the chair
has asked me to sort of walk you through
uh what I'll call the word document
which has my notations a little bit as
to as to what we're doing so uh I can go
through it section by section and if
anybody has questions just stop me or if
I'm going too slowly uh nudge me along
and I'll go quicker um the first section
basically just takes out the 420 4722
uh City Grant of power for codes because
we move it into
155a that's essentially what we're
trying to do in HB 244 anyway but where
these sections were in midair uh being
amended it seemed like the right time to
just put them where they belong and and
then not have to move them again later
uh under the other bill um the second
Bill I'm sorry the second section gets
to the definition of local enforcement
agency
uh first it I'm
sorry okay so are you are you looking at
my Amendment at at the
amendment so the first first section of
that has to do with RSA 4722 and and
deletes
it I hope we're looking at the same
document or this is going to get
difficult should we we should wait till
we get
there I feel your pain yes um okay so
the second section tries to clean up the
def definition of local enforcement
agency uh one we we refer to 67210 where
municipality takes the broad you know
cities towns Village districts all that
stuff and defines it um we've settled on
the term enforcement mechanism which is
the the switch whereby a municipality
decides to either enforce the State
Building Code or not uh there are
numerous terms used throughout the
statutes that's the one that seems to be
used in the field and it it's already
used in
155a um and then in terms of the the
general broad scope of the building code
we've used the language out of the model
codes because it's very close to what
was already there but it just it keeps
the model codes and the statutes in sync
and we're not running around amending
everything uh to meet the statute so any
questions on paragraph two
I forgive me
that I I think there's General agreement
that any construction in a building
falls into one or more of these
yeah okay a number of these references
as you see in part three and four simply
take existing references to what I'll
call the 67x series 674 and so forth and
switch them to
155a uh you know where they land on in
in a minute here so three and four
simply change those references um
[Music]
five we took the fire code out of there
so that's just a reference
thing all right so
local number six is the is the B of this
thing um we start off by essentially
combining language from
67451 for towns and cities and
4722 which was just for cities and put
them in one place and said basically you
can decide to enforce the building code
or not about 141 municipalities in New
Hampshire currently enforce the building
code that covers a broad swath of the
population
obviously and then there's X number of
of smaller jurisdictions that do not so
this simply is language that's already
there and says you're empowered to adopt
an enforcement mechanism a local
enforcement agency and then enforce the
code uh the language about adopting a
nationally recognized code not included
in State Building Code was worked out
last year under SP 437 that's important
it's been there since 2002 when State
Building Code started it allows
municipalities to adopt a housing or a
property maintenance code where there
was a dis decision way back not to do
that on a Statewide basis but it's very
important that the people who want to
adopt it can continue to do so um while
at the same time eliminating the ability
of municipalities to adopt later
additions of the codes that are in the
building code so if we're on one
addition of the international building
code nobody can jump to the newer
addition through
Amendment no it
it the first paragraph uh where it says
the local legislative body May adopt a
nationally recognized code not included
in and not inconsistent with the State
Building Code and then the accept is for
a similar scope that's how we got rid of
later
additions it would effectively
prohibit it might prohibit
municipalities from adopting a housing
code housing and Property Maintenance
codes are sort of similar if not the
same idea so that's the the code that
would allow a municipal inspector to say
your lead paint is falling off the walls
those kinds of things
we didn't get to amendments yet this is
talking about adopting a code amendments
are in the next
paragraph rip I take could I have you
use your microphone so when you yeah no
problem so first we we basically say you
can enforce the building codee if you
want as a
municipality secondly we say you can
adopt additional codes that's that's
word for word what's in the statute
today and that specifically
allows as I said the adoption of a
housing or a property maintenance code
which is not covered by the state
building
code and then prohibits through the
scope statement if we're on the 2021 you
know swimming pool code nobody can go to
the 2024 swimming pool code they've got
to stick with the addition that we're on
that's that's language that was worked
out last year with SP
437 okay so far okay all right now we
talk about amendments so the first
sentence uh amendments implementing the
issuance of permits the collection of
fees and the issuance of permits and
certificates of occupancy simply
reference to two statute two statutes
today that Reserve those three items
issuance of permits collection of fees
and C of O's certificates of occupancies
for the
municipalities the state has nothing
state code folks have nothing to say
about how they do it what they do with
it or not um and that simply allows them
to continue to do amendments to
implement that stuff that's the part of
their responsibilities uh
today um then it talks about out or
other administrative functions shall be
reserved for the municipalities provided
they're not less stringent than the
State Building Code and they get
confirmed through the bcrb we can get to
that in a minute so this basically
allows people to amend um things to do
with plan reviews and permits and all of
that administrative stuff without
allowing them to do technical
amendments fairly critical I I mean you
know this city of Manchester operates
their building department differently
than some town of 4,000 per people so
they've got to have the ability to to
massage that chapter one stuff to um to
to fit into the way they've operated you
know right along but again not
permitting technical amendments through
that
sentence we go on to just reinforce that
in case you didn't understand that it's
only administrative no amendments to the
technical requirements of the State
Building Code or permitted period we
have a question rep
sitech there was a sense on the part of
one or more people that if for whatever
the reason the state code bogged down
we've seen that in the past one issue
bogs down the whole state code and it
doesn't get updated for a number of
years back in the 2009 to 2015 cycle
there was a major delay um these
individuals felt that at that point it
was dangerous enough uh that amendments
ought to be
permitted it's a sentence in there
but it concerns me that this may be an
opportunity to get around the intent of
the Bill of your Amendment it it that's
my concern yeah get around or seem to
not align with the overall intent of the
bill but only if the if the updates to
the State Building Code get delayed if
that sounds to me like uh this could be
eliminated and you're talking about
something that's 15 years ago and I
don't I just don't see a clear and
present danger of that that this this
this Belt doesn't need suspenders
too it can be eliminated you're the
legislature
yes my point is it could be
eliminated uh without any real harm to
the intent of the
bill I would agree that it it's it's
opposite of the overall intent of this
bill
um and again if that sentence stays it
requires the confirmation process that's
in in place
today all right so are we okay on that
first first long paragraph under 155
A3 the next part of this Roman numeral
one simply vacuums up a bunch of stuff
that's splattered in other places in the
code today there's nothing new in there
it simply says if you're going to have
an enforcement mechanism you have to
have a building official you have to
have an appeals board you have to have a
fee structure that's all language that's
in there now there's some duplication
there's actually a section in there in
673 that's a holdover from back when
municipalities adopted their own codes
um so it simply combines and and
collates the the precise same issues
that are are still in there it requires
uh the the establishment of who has the
authority to set a fee schedule whether
it's the city council the board of
Selectmen the building inspector himself
or whoever it is all in the statute
today any questions on Roman numeral
one Roman numeral 2
who uh for some reason New Hampshire
makes certificates of occupancy optional
carries that language right through from
the current
code uh Roman uh yeah Roman numeral 3 is
basically in the code today uh it
basically says State stay out of
employment issues you know the
municipalities have the right to put
whoever they want in that position to do
the job uh we made one minor Amendment
there where we say existing or amended
ordinances they may want to change these
over time uh but that those ordinances
still
stand yes sir Mr Sherman is that subb is
that a grandfather
clause only as it as it involves
employment
issues yeah this is a very limited thing
where you know the board of Selectmen
hired a building inspector we're not
telling them who to hire and so forth
right um what time the office is open or
whatever it
is um Roman numeral 4 is a little bit of
a duplicate but it just says whatever
amendments come out of the previous
sections still have to come back to the
bcrb for confirmation yes sir Mr Sherman
confirmation does that is that word
shouldn't that word be
approval Mr I can hear Mr Mr ran Court
giggling back there that word um
resulted two years ago when the when the
bcrb confirmation process was first
implemented in
2023 um and it was
carefully worded because we have no now
again this is this is when we were
confirming technical amendments as we do
today we have no input on whether that
technical amendment makes any sense or
not
we're only looking at whether it's less
stringent than the State Building Code
then it doesn't and then send it to the
Fire Marshall to be sure that it doesn't
conflict with the fire code so all we're
looking at is does it comply with the
statute that says it it references a
specific section in a specific code is
it less stringent and is it um is it
does it conflict with a fire code if
somebody wants an amendment that says
all walls have to be painted purple we
have nothing to say about whether that's
a good idea idea or not so that's why we
didn't use the term approved we use
confirmed that's in the statute well I'm
not convinced personally okay I like I
like the word approval because suppose
you don't confirm what's that mean it's
not
approved the the statute says it can't
be enforced if it's not confirmed but so
there's a you're telling me there's a
difference in word but not a difference
in meaning from approval yeah I would I
would say 12
right again we we made a little bit of
an effort to try and not muck with
things that are there today other than
as the as we address this amendment
but
uh all right so then Roman numeral 5
again picks up some stuff from other
places basically just you know redefines
it defines a municipality so we're
talking about um and again repeats no
local modification except as permitted
in this section um and as I understand
it there's a difference between enacting
an ordinance and enforcing an ordinance
so we've tried to cover that base
um and basically just ties down this
prohibition on technical
amendments that's where the teeth are in
this bill
yes I believe so
yeah Roman numeral 6 part 1 and two just
repeat um language that's in the in the
statute
today last year through S SP
437 U all of these local ordinances were
intended to be brought to the surface
and submitted for
confirmation that process is still just
beginning
so we tried to carry in this amendment
the current language flushing all this
stuff to the surface for a lookie we've
had significant problems um with
literally every am every ordinance that
we've seen so there's a lot of work
going on out there at the municipalities
to redo their ordinances I've spent a
lot of time on the phone I've personally
talked with everybody who's submitted
one many people who have not submitted
yet um are busy working working on them
because they know they've got problems
uh it's amazing what's hanging out there
in Old ordinances that haven't been
looked at in a long time um so that that
language just continues the process
that's there today depending on the
implementation of this bill because
obviously this this amendment if it goes
through would require some changes to
those ordinances we may want to kick
I'll get to this in a minute we may want
to kick this out so that we we sweep it
all up in one one exercise rather than
having them rewrite their ordinance and
then bang in July they get to do it all
over again but we can we can talk about
that in a minute so paragraph 6 one and
two right out of the existing
statute I'm Mr chairman I'm having
trouble with these dates no local
Amendment shall be enforced if it has
not been submitted to the bill brcb
within 60 days of the effective date of
this paragraph which
is uh
I guess that's a is there July 1 in
there what what's the whole purpose of
July 1 this bill this bills got uh got a
year uh doesn't take the effective date
is a year after passage so that really
Mak sense to put that in we we may have
a I think you found an an editing issue
here that effective data the paragraph
Was from the last statute which was July
of last year so this now we've got a
parag
here and that would need to be
corrected well what what happened was
that that the bill allowed a 60-day
window where all they had to do was send
us an email and say here's our ordinance
and then it relieved the time pressure
but it said if you didn't submit it
within 60 days you could not enforce the
ordinance about 10 municipalities
submitted it within that 60-day
window okay um
but this is not going to permit
amendments after July 1st 2024 is
that any such ordinance paragraph two
says if you if you have an ordinance on
or after July 24 you can't enforce it
unless we confirm it the earlier
paragraphs now say in the amendment here
so you can't have technical
amendments can can you suggest uh uh
editing change to uh that you've for the
dates is what I'm I think the editing
changes simply in in paragraph number
one
um instead of saying within 60 days of
the effected date of this
paragraph We should say within 60 days
of July 1st 2024
I'm sorry my pen is run out of ink here
but
um that would be an
appropriate thank
you but that time has
passed the ordinances are still out
there though if we lose
that we we go back and start that whole
thing all over again whereas the fact is
out of the 141 municipalities 131 of
them plus or minus missed that deadline
so their ordinances as of this point in
time are not
enforceable so you would you're can you
would within 60 days of July 1 is that
202 July 1st 24 yeah okay so that should
be should be changed yeah
okay well there goes your career in OSS
we're doing fine till then
ah really
okay very perceptive questions yeah
thank you
uh and the last two paragraphs seven and
eight simply bring language that's been
in there for a long time prohibiting the
one and two family dwelling Sprinklers
and allowing for uh any heat Source in a
building that is word for word carried
over or left there
um I guess I wasn't finished excuse me
that means if it's a one or two family
house they could just plane build it
they don't need to let you know it has
to be inspected by either the fire
marshal or the local Authority but they
don't have to let you know about
it no this just prohibits municipalities
from writing amendments that require
sprinklers in one and two family
dwellings wait that I'm on Roman numeral
I'm sorry I'm ahead again I'm almost at
the end I'll catch up to you in a
minute all right so then paragraph
number seven and eight simply realign
some
references um paragraph number nine
clarifies okay so this is the bcrb
confirmation process and it really
clarifies that we're reviewing
ordinances not and the ordinances
include the Amendments but it's the
ordinance that we're we're confirming um
and then a couple of references there uh
but that process just continues the way
it has now for two years
um number 10 red does an ordinance but
we should note that there's another bill
floating through the house that would
would change that
um number 11 is a reference oh number 11
is an error in the current statute uh it
talks about
U yeah local Boards of
appeal pretty sure we've got that got
that
correct
um number 12 changes
references and then back on 13 under
repealing
um so it's a difficult to write an
amendment to a bill because they don't
know if we're amending the original
statute or the bill but this basically
puts the confirmation process back in in
gear or leaves it there as the case may
be yes sir it's your intention that this
your word document that you described it
replaces the entire Bill yes so it's
everything we got the enacted Clause
yeah yeah um and then we repeal 4722 and
67451 which is where a lot of this stuff
came from but we've covered everything
that's in there so then on the effective
date as I as I alluded to previously it
it seems to me that leaving a fairly
significant window to catch up to all
this stuff will allow the municipalities
particularly the towns that are locked
into town meeting schedules of which
most of them have missed for this year
give them enough time that they can redo
their ordinance we confirm it they go to
the town meeting the city councils and
town councils have more more
flexibility um but I'm I'm thinking that
12 months uh would be a would be a good
time
frame Mr Sherman could you speak um to
the fire codes that we're moving
uh Sean will throw something at me if I
get this wrong but uh Sean if you want
to Mr Timmy if you want
to good morning uh Sean Tumi State Fire
Marshal for the record um so I think one
of the things that has been talked about
is trying to make sure that building
code related items are in the 155
building code statute and the fire code
related items are in 15 3 the fire code
related statute um in 1535 which talks
predominately about the state fire code
in general there has been a
uh in paragraph five is a section that
points back to 155 A3 which as you heard
this morning uh Phil's talk is is going
to change and also talks about uh 4722
so I think what we just need to do is uh
hearing all of this is I need to come up
with some language for you that will
just help clean up in 1535 and then 1534
just the process if there's an intent to
keep some local amendments I know the
intent is to restrict this I think
similar to on the building code uh
having some ability for the
municipalities to have some
administrative changes makes sense um
the technical changes I think are the
bigger problem um some of the process
related stuff at the local level um
would just need to craft some language
to marrow what's going to happen in the
building
code uh thank you for taking my question
so uh you bring up a good point and I
would hope that you could uh kind of um
help me clarify this a little bit but
what's the difference between
administrative versus technical uh in
that term sure so I think that
um I'll take the the driveway example
for instance it's there's some
Provisions in there that talk about uh
driveway with fire department access
things like that there was some there's
some stuff in statue that changed to
bring it down to 12 feet that happened
last year but if the municipality
through the planning board decides that
like we want 14 or 16 or something like
that uh that gets to be a problem I
think um when they get into the weeds of
a sprinkler design or something like
that that that kind of gets that seems
to be a problem for contractors owners
and design professionals when and uh
when the state fire code says one thing
and then they go uh to a much deeper
level the ad administrative stuff that
we think about is um what I think about
it is the the pole station for the fire
alarm that's out by the exit out here
what type of key is it the what's what
cylinder should it be uh the fire
department connection for a sprinkler
system is it a 4 in is it a 5 in is it
two two you know two two and a halfs or
something like that
um uh you know the the key box that we
the nox boxes is the common one but
there's different manufacturers key
secure you know things like that just
trying to be CL transparent with the the
people the you the end users of the
codes I think some of that being there
whether we call it regul what we call it
but I think that's helpful for the end
users that that's transparent at the
local level um and the the current fire
code says it's kind of up to the HJ so
it I think that's the up to the HJ is a
concern for a lot of people out there
because it's like well I say one thing
and another Fire official might say
another thing but if we can be more
transparent of what the intent is at a
local level uh that's I think that's
important uh so does that mean that the
administrative rules would be uh
unamendable across the the entire State
and the technical uh codes would be the
ones that would be amendable so uh thank
you so the technical codes would any
technical requests for changes would
come up through the State Building the
board of Fire Control and then so the
board of Fire Control would receive an
amendment have a public
hearing decide whether it's makes sense
or not to amend the state fire code it
will come back to the general court for
ratification in in that
process administrative Amendment what
kind of key you want for your pole
station or fire alarm panel could be
handled with local level um that's sort
of what we've been thinking about how to
exactly phrase that still working I
think we're still trying to figure that
out but um in the spirit of what's
trying to be done here just trying to
reserve some ability I think for some
transparency at the local level so I'll
use keep using the firearm example you
come in and put all the wrong keys in
right that and the fire alarm come say
well we don't really have that key uh we
have this type of key and all the other
buildings in the community um it you
know I think from a ease of use in
operational efficiency perspective it
makes sense to standardize key if the
contractors know about that ahead of
time they can say they can spe I want
this cylinder and it's easy similar to a
a sprinkler connection or something like
that um I can think of some examples on
the fire system for the water supply to
say like we we would like you know we
want a 20,000 or 30,000 gallon tank
instead of being kind of all over the
place some of those types of
examples thank you
I get that far Phil's wh right here so
there's an international fire code that
a few of the bigger cities adopt right
now that's similar to NFPA 1 but it
helps with their local enforcement a
little easier because it ties in the
local standards we've uh we have allowed
uh as long as it doesn't conflict with
the state fire code allow the
communities to currently adopt that at
the local level similar to as we talked
about like the property maintenance code
so you know
that a it's up to leave it up to you
guys as far as you know as policy-wise
what we want to do
but okay so um amending the fire code
placement um
language um you had mentioned that
there's a Senate bill that may be more
appropriate to do your Amendment through
is that correct instead of the one we're
working on here yeah thank you so
tomorrow there's a senate uh Hearing in
Edna um the Senate Bill 94 I believe
that has uh is doing a very similar
thing to restrict local amendments it
does specifically call the fire code in
that bill so um this where this one
doesn't it just fire code I think is
sort of in there but it doesn't
explicitly talk about the fire code
maybe that would be a more appropriate
place we can do it and then would clean
up in the end through through the
process I'm happy to work with the uh
Senate on that thank you thank you are
there any other
questions all right thank you thank
you a discussion on this particular
Amendment sounds like sounds to me like
at a minimum we got to change the uh
that effective date of the paragraph As
uh Mr Sherman said just as a as a
technical change to the bill but uh he
seems done a pretty good job as far as
I'm
concerned uh are there copies of the uh
the bill up front or there's copies of
the bill but not what of his amend
changes I got this off the where did I
get it I sent it to you oh you yeah okay
that's right because I don't have
legislative email I got to go to it to
get that straightened out um I can email
you it yes that would be appreciate
thank you okay um are you comfortable
voting before you get the copy do you
understand enough to I don't know
necessarily if I would feel comfortable
voting before I had an opportunity to
fully read everything
okay so you're not comfortable making a
recommendation uh at this moment no I I
mean personally I think like uh it it
would be beneficial to have an
opportunity to read everything first so
uh maybe if we could come back to this
uh if if we could have an emailed out
now and then uh come back to this a
little bit later so that we can kind of
read it
uh at least sometime before we finish
this meeting okay sounds good
absolutely okay um I might suggest that
we have a standup meeting before regular
uh Edna meeting to because I don't think
representative Howard is going to be
surprised or upset but I think we should
observe due process and we want this
we'd like this changed so it'll I'm
suggesting a standup meeting before our
next Edna meeting to to wrap this up but
I'm I'm satisfied with it I don't see
representative dargy or Davis jumping up
and down and I think we should
accommodate representative Howard so
agree I I I do agree with your uh your
comments representative scitech I don't
necessarily think that there's going to
be too much of an issue it's just again
due process so thank you okay thank
you yes can we ask Mr Sherman to uh take
a walk over to OS and do our work for us
and get
a oh no we have to do it don't we yes so
I will I will take a walk over and then
we will schedule um another meeting
subcommittee meeting before we bring it
before the whole committee does that
sound good okay thank
you okay um let's move on to HB 244
Mr Sherman would you like to come back
to the witness table thank
you madam chair members of the committee
Phil Sherman chair of the building code
review board
um I'll refer today to the 67x series
just because it uses fewer syllables but
it's basically 6 RSA 671 through
wherever it ends
679 um back in the day before
2002 uh when the first Statewide
building code was adopted much of the
municipal actions uh to adopt a building
code were splattered through the 67x
series many of those still remain today
so the enforcement mechanism we talked
about on the last bill um appeals Roots
uh that kind of stuff just is all over
the place in there uh we heard from many
of the building officials that there is
a lot of confusion in the enforcement
Community
particularly um especially because some
of these folks wear two hats they
they're both the building inspector and
the zoning administrator and it's
difficult to parse out when you're
operating in which Arena uh furthermore
some of the municipal actions sit in 67x
and some sit in
155a so this was an exercise that that
at a at a global level was intended to
be nothing but editorial to take all the
building code stuff out of the 67x
series and find a home in some kind of
order in
155a some of those sections we propose
moving ahead of time just in in
428 um so that's all this bill was
intended to do as I understand it and
I'm not digested the other stuff that
was added into the actual bill but
there's some other tentacles in there
that got added by someone somewhere
along the way that I'm not here to talk
about but the general intent is to
Simply take the building you know
building inspector building codes
building code Boards of appeal things
like that and move it into uh 155a
without changing anybody's
responsibilities so this bill is if we
got it right does not change anybody's
responsibilities
here's the issue that I see um it
resulted in about 20s something pages of
ink that got added to
155a and in my reading of it I don't
think we need a lot of that the land use
chapters have you know a long history of
of a legal context that's grown up
around zoning appeals and all that kind
of stuff much of which may not be
necessary for a building code appeal uh
particularly on the appeal side so I
think that with the time to put a lot of
eyes on this because we need we need
educated eyes from the landu side from
the enforcement community and from the
code writing Community to make sure we
get it right uh we can shrink that down
and give everybody a package that they
want and the zoning stuff stays the way
it is all we did was just edit out
building code stuff as we went along uh
if we got it right um so I I I certainly
would support you know defer ing this
TimeWise to where we have time to to
just get a lot of people to look at this
the municipal Association has offered
some time uh with their people who
really get into both sides of this thing
to look at it um but they indicate to me
that that's going to take some number of
months to you know to come up with that
that
support so that's where we are on this
today any questions or
discussion so you're we're suggest
putting uh putting this not um to in
study well I'm suggesting that perhaps
we um recommend to retain this bill
retain sorry so that more eyes can look
at it and you know edit
it yeah I think if we could work on this
over the summer uh we would come out of
it with a with a good package
that I haven't heard anybody who's
disagreed with the premise of it but
there's a lot of ink moving around in
here so
okay so
um um so could we vote uh do a vote to
re recommend retaining this
bill second that okay uh representative
scitec when you're ready would you like
to
oh we'll vote out to show a hand so 5 Z
that okay great
yes thank you
the last bill to discuss today is House
Bill
96 oh actually with respect to our very
first bill do we what where is what is
its status because we didn't really vote
that we just we're going to have another
subcommittee meeting so correct I'm
going toing bring it to OS to have a um
an official draft Amendment and then we
will look at it discuss it and uh take a
vote to bring back to the committee
recessed
here move to
recess um
hb9 once again I'd like to call uh Mr
Sherman to the witness
table Phil Sherman chair of the building
code review board
um I'm not here to take a position on
this bill uh I'm here to provide uh
technical backup for you all um and the
one thing that I was asked to just
explain to the to the committee here
subcommittee is our cycle of reviewing
the updated energy code so we are are as
of this coming month starting our review
of the
2024 uh ICC codes building code and so
forth energy code among that um the
schedule would lead to a submittal to
The Advisory the legislative advisory
committee
uh around November 1st shortly before
that uh and then through the next spring
of 2026 the legislature does their thing
and then the codes presumably would be
updated or not U the following July 1 um
so that's that's just information for
you so um in looking at this um perhaps
this bill is a little premature in
nature because you're still reviewing it
you you'll still have another year or so
to go through the
process of looking at this
code this code proposes to adopt a 2021
Edition you you may remember we're on
the 2018 now we held it back last year
it's published every three years um so
this this proposes the 2021
International energy conservation code
we're reviewing the 2024 we reviewed
2021 last year here so effectively our
our committee within the bcrb is is
looking at a jump of of two additions
and the impact of
that is the energy code part of the
building code or is
separate
yes the the New Hampshire State Building
Code consists of eight codes seven of
them uh prom ated by the International
Code Council the building code the
residential code the energy code among
those the electrical code is p published
by the National Fire Protection
Association that's the eighth code that
we're actually updating with other
legislation this year um within that
pile of codes though there's a hierarchy
where things flow out of the building
code so if if I go to the electrical
code they don't have some of the
administrative functions on permitting
and things things like that that's
located in the in the building code so
by Statute there's eight codes in the in
the State Building Code eight model
codes but in in practice in the field
they come through a hierarchy where the
building code then says go here go here
go
here mostly for the administrative
stuff is that confusing enough and where
does energy fit into that energy is one
of these codes that's published by the
International Code Council So currently
we're on the
2021 ICC codes except for energy which
we held back you all held back at at the
code right so if we'll just say if this
bill passes and goes into effect um it
would only be in effect for a year is
that correct if the if the 2024 code
predes it would be in effect for roughly
a year yeah
okay
thank representative
darg uh during the testimony uh various
people uh discussed uh the cost of going
from 2018 to 2021 there were different
uh opinions as to what the the added
cost is does your group have a an idea
as to what the right number
is so my my function primarily is to
manage the process
um we we took when during the discussion
about whether to adopt the 2021 code we
took testimony through the committee and
then at the board uh through numerous
people from every side of the equation
and all I can can report is that the
vote was N9 to4 to stay on the 2018 code
so there were there were opposing views
Pres presented as they continue to be um
were
there various discrepancies on uh cost
estimates at that time
also there were differences of of what
was being reported
yes okay thank
you R scitec um basically I I've thought
about I took the minutes for it I
listened to people and I don't really
know whom to trust
because
um there's more than with most bills it
seems that there's stuff that I will
never know really what's going on I
heard one person say 177,000 another
person said 2300 and they were both
quoting repres Senator Shaheen if this
bill really costs
$2,300 none of us would be here we'd be
all at Dunkin Donuts nobody believe I
don't believe $2,300 I don't know if I
can believe
177,000 so I
am uh I am basically
suspicious that this is um that this is
a good measure if this is only intended
to save energy we're not talking about
1955 with single pane windows we're
chasing the last few percent even in
2018 people were very ener she conscious
ever since the oil embargo we've been
watching energy and I don't know that
the state needs to tell consumers we're
going to chase your last everyone we're
going to chase now I'm not talking I'm
not talking to you Mr Sherman I'm
talking to the committee really that I
just
don't I have I don't know whom to trust
I think we're chasing the last few
percent and I'll let the cons my
personal opinion is let the consumer
Chase it for himself and his Builder
we're not we're not talking 19 again
1956 with single pain drafty windows so
here I am it's just a I don't I don't
believe the bill or believe I don't know
whom to trust thank
you yes representative uh thank you for
taking my uh question so I understand
that you've been kind of uh suggesting
that we move over to the 2024 energy
code no please don't misunderstand me
our board is only starting the review of
the 2024 which is required by Statute
okay so no decisions no recommendations
are coming out of either me or the board
at this point so let let me let me
clarify uh so I understand that you're
reviewing the uh the 2024 uh codes right
now and that you're going to produce a
recommendation uh after you finish those
so my question is would you prefer that
we wait until those recommendations come
out before we take
action I I would prefer to bypass that
question I I think it's a decision for
you thank you appreciate that walking a
bit of a tight rope here so thank you Mr
Sherman thank you any other questions
for Mr Sherman no thank you thank you
yeah I think that um you know you've
made a good point as there still re
reviewing 2024 I think that you've made
good points especially that uh we do
know that we are in a housing crisis in
New Hampshire and adding any extra costs
in a mandate form um is not going to
help the the crisis especially since
people are free to you know incorporate
these codes when they're building their
home if they so choose
um this isn't a hearing um
um I think he did that during the
hearing but go
ahead yes this is this is exp parte
we're hearing him we're not hearing is
we either have a full hearing or not let
him
speak uh my name is Paul beus I'm
ex-president of the ashray New Hampshire
ashray organization I'm not a lobbyist
I'm just here to provide
information
yes I have substantiation documentation
here on substantiating that I'd like to
share the I you shared that with the
committee already didn't you in your
testim Shar it with the chair yeah and I
think she um distributed it yes okay so
if you have if are there any different
numbers that you have for us today or is
there's a couple different reports
there's also a report that compares the
two methods that were used for cost
analysis
that I think would be
Germain Mr beamus do you think it's
worth
$2,300 uh to have a
bill mandating this for everybody
through this for all new housing in the
state if that is that why you're here
for2 yes yes I'm here to for one thing
get the codes consistent right now we
have 2018 for energy in 2021 for
everything else Energy Efficiency is
important it's actually a 15%
uh Improvement in Energy Efficiency not
small numbers it's a 15% Improvement in
Energy Efficiency and it also is
important for for the health of the
individuals which is not included in a
simple six-year payback cost kind of
analysis health of the occupants is uh
important here and this 2021 code
improves The Vapor Barrier which
improves human health by providing
better indoor air quality thank you I
think you mentioned that in your
testimony at the hearing mhm
so I U will pass these out I guess to
make sure sure you can pass them out
sure
part of my point here is information
equality everybody getting the same
level of information I'm not sure this
level of information was known when the
discussion took place at the building
review board originally there are two
documents here the first one is
from the Department of energy talking
about costs associated with this you'll
notice the cost of $2,300 is actually an
average it's actually lower than that
for our climate zone and uh also the
original report that was cited by um the
committee subcommittee was uh
overstating cost quite a bit
y thank you for taking my question so I
know that in uh some of these documents
it's referencing 30 years for a lot of
the numberers
uh is there an estimated uh average
return as to how much somebody would be
likely to save over that
period yes um there's quite a bit of
savings over the period I mean you're
looking at an individual cost in the
range of $
11,200 if you uh actually use a mortgage
and and borrow money to to do these you
know if the incremental cost were added
to your mortgage your payback uh in
terms of cash would take place within
two years uh typically six years a
simple payback but simple payback is not
a great method to use here because it
does not include life cycle savings like
life cycle savings over the life of the
home or building are in more of the
range of $30,000 20 to $30,000 over the
life let me let me also just point out
that this extends the life of the
building uh upwards of about 30 years
because it eliminates the ability for
the building to absorb moisture in both
Direction directions which causes mold
and rot so proper Vapor Barrier is very
important in terms of being able to
manage not only indoor air quality but
also extend the life of the building
through the elimination of moisture
coming in and out of the
walls representative
scitec Mr beamus I'm thinking about this
and my uh sense is you've made those
points and I really have to think about
them I'm not
I as you can tell I'm not fan of this
but I'm not sitting here because I don't
want to listen have to listen to people
I think my feeling on this is uh not
personally is not yet I really want to
know more about this I'm hearing you I
want to I'm not sure what kind of
research I'm going to do uh but I'd like
to get you and Maybury in the same room
and see who comes out on top basically
is kind of we're okay in some sense I I
mean I know where you both are I'm
certainly willing to do that I'm not I'm
not prepared for this yet I uh I want to
give
this I have to think about this I
appreciate that consideration is really
what I think makes sense I'm trying to
Simply make sure everybody has the same
information uh on the topic yeah we do
thank you
all right um I understand but this isn't
a hearing so we're going to cut off test
testimony right we're not going to be
taking anymore okay um
so discussion on HB 96 anybody have
discussion oh I I mean I think that it's
there there have been some key points
that have been brought up I mean a we
have to consider the fact that the uh
building code review board is looking at
uh the 2024 codes right now and they are
going to be providing recommendations
next year so it is something where uh do
we want to hold off but at the same time
uh you know looking at how we have pass
a number of the other codes up to the
2021 uh time period it is kind of
something where we have lagged behind a
little bit on this I do think that there
are some good points that have been made
in terms of the total potential lifetime
savings and uh it is potentially worth
considering so uh with that
uh Rite
Tech are you making a motion because my
motions are going to be if if I make the
motion it's either going to be itl
retain yeah I mean I I guess I'll move
uh OTP
then
okay is there a
second
um would you like to speak to your
motion uh I mean as as I said I feel
like this is something where uh it would
be good to have an affirmative motion
going into our discussion as a full
committee I think that this is something
where we should be uh thinking of this
in a positive mindset and not
necessarily thinking that we should just
reject it immediately uh that's
partially why I I think that we need to
move forward with an OTP motion uh so
with
that um I will just say that I will be
voting against the a to pass motion
because I think it's premature I think
that uh we've heard that the building
code review board is still working on
that and uh reviewing it and
um so I'll be voting against that motion
and
recommending no on that
motion um representative scitech call
for the vote Yes that'd be great
U no is uh ought to pass on I'm voting
no on ought to pass
okay I'm voting no no
yes yes
three2 okay recommend that and we will
speak to um the minority uh opinion on
that well we we'll discuss it in yeah at
the committee
sure so uh
we uh have no other bills to discuss
this morning and um we've recessed uh on
House Bill 428 while I go to OSS and get
that Amendment drafted and um there'll
be a notice in the calendar when our
next subcommittee we are in recess on
that Bill yes
okay so I will close the subcommittee
hearing on House Bill 428 24496
just one
clear
e
e for